reg if I said the series will go five
games or seven games you don't get 65 or
seven what are you taking seven no okay
I we talked about this last week you had
Cleveland I had Golden State you
wouldn't give a number i said in seven
but in my opinion it's still not a
series until someone loses home court so
if Golden State all they really have to
do is when their home games and they win
the series which would be in seven what
we expected this from Cleveland look
they were god-awful in Games one and two
and you know you could go around and
point fingers at you know a number of
people but everyone did not play or
perform up to up to their abilities and
in Game three LeBron James got more help
plain and simple and you know it's you
know it's simple when you go out there
and play with effort and you play as a
team and you share the basketball and
you hustle and bottom line you make
shots Junior Smith made shots eight
total points in Games one and two and he
has 20 in Game three you know when the
ball goes through the basket good things
happen obviously and they made shots
Kyrie Irving made shots he made plays he
didn't do that in Games one and two
what's wrong with steph curry something
is wrong and it's interesting because
when I watch him it's more because i'm
watching him off the ball when he when
he's handling the basketball she looks
fine to me but Steve Kerr and Golden
State there are running so many sets and
they've done this all year with Klay and
Steph off the basketball with Andre and
dream on handling the basketball which
is smart because you got your two best
shooters coming off screens it just adds
another wrinkle to your offense but when
I'm watching him off the basketball it's
he doesn't have that explosion he
doesn't have that stop and go that I'm
accustomed to seeing now they've come
out and say there's nothing wrong with
the ankle there's nothing wrong with the
knee it would not surprise me when this
is all over said and done it's going to
come out
that he's in far worse shape than what
we assumed he was they could say he's
okay because you don't want to put a
target by saying something's wrong with
your knee or ankle but I really think
something is affecting him because he
does not look the same off the
basketball he looks fine when he's
handling it coming off you know those
high screen and rolls but when he's
underneath so you know and especially in
the finals in a playoff basketball when
you get to hold a little bit more when i
watch Dellavedova and Shumpert and those
guys holding him he can't get free so
that's telling me alone that his lower
body his legs are not strong at all what
I thought was strange or maybe telling
is steve kerr takes Steph Curry out last
night oh yeah are you okay yes like why
would he ask if he's okay again there
they will not say this publicly but when
this is all said and done and I think
we're kind of getting a glimpse of it by
him kind of pulling out of real as well
saying he needs to rest the knee and and
the ankle that there's something more
that is there again I applaud him for
playing through pain and you know
playing you know hurt or injured but
there's a little bit more to it but we
can't make excuses you know if he's able
to lace them up and go out there and
play then we're assuming he's got a
hundred percent I'm just saying when
this series is over and the dust settles
I would not be surprised later on down
the road in the summer it comes out that
his knee or ankle or both were given him
a lot of trouble assuming he's cleared
for Game four what do you do with Kevin
Love I would bring him off the bench
yeah me too look I'm I'm a creature of
habit and something has been working
with Richard Jefferson in with that
starting lineup and we saw this last
year with Steve Kerr wouldn't he decided
to go small with Andre Iguodala and
bingeing Bogut look it's going to help
your second unit and his role doesn't
change I think it helps solidify that
second unit if you have an all-star like
Kevin Love coming off I mean this is not
going to be his normal was you know role
you know come next year but for this
particular series I think you've got to
bring them off the bench and we talked
about
last week I said that the Golden State
Warriors were going to take one of the
big three out for Cleveland and it was
going to probably be Kevin Love they
were going to put him in a lot of pick
and rolls now obviously one game took
him out because of the concussion but
that was going to be the goal in this
series it was that Golden State was
going to try to take Kevin Love out of
this series and they have you ever have
a concussion yes how long were you out
we didn't have this protocol so I pretty
much came back and played but you know
it's easy for us to say well he should
be playing in light of everything that
we are starting to find out you know
obviously through the movie concussion
and threw the football injuries and you
know some of these football deaths of
junior sale and so forth we got to be
real careful because it's easy for us to
be on the sidelines and say he should
play and I applaud Kevin Love for saying
he wanting to play and being frustrated
with the protocol of going through it
and not being cleared end of the day he
wanted to play but the doctors did not
clear him to play so people need to
understand that so for them to say he's
soft and okay this is an old school he
would be playing we've got to be real
this is just a basketball game people
this is life that he's dealing with so
I'm sure he'll be cleared for game four
but we've got to be real careful on how
we approached by calling guys soft by
not playing with concussion and ever
because of everything we know now about
head injuries but how did it affect you
when you played with a concussion or
concussion symptoms I was a little loopy
you know you know I i had my symptoms
and maybe that's why I'm a little crazy
dad because of those concussions but um
you've got to be careful and I applied
this procedure being in place because of
athletes we are our own worst enemy yeah
we always feel that we could go out
there and at sixty seventy eighty
percent we want to perform but we've got
to be careful especially with a head
injury he's Reggie Miller the Hall of
Famer NBA on TNT analyst joining us do
watch Game of Thrones
I do not it feels like you said is that
the show of the NBA like what if you
pulled the players and said what what is
your binge-watching show I think I don't
know a lot about the show but it's like
a ruthless show right it's like a
cutthroat show so that's pretty much the
NBA and walking up white guys kind of
get into it yeah the walking dead is
another one yes well who I love though I
love the walking dead and fear the
walking dead or fear that fear the dead
i think it's called Oh mclovin oh you
mean like the post show the show right
after walking dead said know that
there's a spin-off isn't there fear the
walking dead like how it originated it's
about like the plane and all that stuff
perceptive know like how the virus
originally started in a lot fanjul oh
yeah and it all starts on the plane with
the plane and all the people are going
crazy in there the glove in what is it
mclovin dude I don't watch walking down
ok but I ok he watched his game of
thrones I do not watch Game of Thrones
I'm sorry what do you been John I'm
binging because I'm now getting caught
up so don't give me a spoiler alert the
good wife the last season so i think i
have four or five more don't stop it I
haven't watched one episode to spoil
looking for you yeah but one of those
that actually I have and they like to
spoil things the good wife I like to
julianna margulies is fantastic that's a
great show what are you talking about I
I know did good wife the good wife is
totally cool i do you watch The
Bachelorette to read no but a reality
show I love now that Simon Cowell
America's Got Talent I love love love we
should come up with a talent we should
go on that no good did you even go on
America's Got Talent reg did you see the
outfit Mel B had on the other last show
well they change outfits a lot but yes
which one the load cut one is that the
one you're talking to and like shoelaces
like that holding back and that's a
cat's of family show somebody's got to
tell Mel B egg come on come on not the
spice girls in
your spices oh my god it was classy stop
it it was male you define it was not
classy stay classy Milby stay classy yep
all the Dan answer wondering if Reggie
watch gilmore girls before games back in
the day to get fired no I did not watch
gilmore games come on now homes in on
that yeah that's fine angel party of
five give me a credit party of five okay
all right but when you would get on the
road you go to a hotel would you rent
movies or would you watch shows I would
watch movies because a lot of times
you'll get a chance to see movies while
they're out in theatres yes the specter
vision you would you know rent a movie
fritzy that's not what Reggie's talking
it's not no no no you without those kind
of movie yeah that's all they are on
there were you were you able to go out
tho do a movie did you guys ever go out
in like in mass when you were to a
patient occasionally yeah you would go
out of the team team movies that's
bonding experience especially on the
road which is you know that's what you
you know dinners movies go bowling
things like that but did you find that
those like you're the guy who is
competitive as a basketball player is
competitive with everything yes yes
everyone has you know a couple guys on
the team that takes it you know there's
supposed to be a fun bonding experience
you know you go out and bowl and you
have a good time and you know you talk
about things but there's a couple guys
on the team they have to just take
everything serious and go to the next
level were you one of those guys I was
one of our guys yeah I was this boiler
yes I always had to take it's just a
competitive edge in me I'm sorry you
can't turn it on it's hard to turn
things off but are you competitive as a
broadcaster I don't know if you can be
competitive as a broadcaster because
usually you're in a two or three man
booth and it's tough to be competitive
because you just want to bring the
action and explain the action to the
people at home so I'll know if you can
be competitive but are you competitive
with Mark Jackson who does the finals
for the market rate I love mark no mark
is fantastic as a broadcaster I wouldn't
be compared mean I don't know
you can be competitive I may be jealous
because they get to the finals games I'm
not competitive on jealous you were
hoping that he would get a head coaching
job right well I'm not gonna rely go
over to AVC or he is fear that's all
jealous that he gets to call the biggest
games no you're a great game like well
they've been terrible games but but just
as they called the final you wouldn't be
traded to the two uh yeah I don't know I
couldn't read it oh oh no I'm not
betraying I love my family I love I
Turner family all right before we leave
what happens in Game four I could see is
very much going back to the bay up to
two but as its barest embarrassed as the
Warriors were and Klay and Steph still
have it through three games don't that
played great if memory they have not
scored 20 between the two of them right
yeah they have not had a 20-point game
so sooner or later they're going to bust
out right yes I could see that happening
in Game four I see the Warriors winning
it four in Game four mmm alright I hope
Cleveland wins just to make it a little
bit of a serious give a little bit of
drama there it's nice but again it's not
a series until someone loses on their
home court so again all Golden State has
to do is win home games and they win
thanks right thank you reggie i
appreciate it all right buddy have a
good weekend we talk to it all right
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience